welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
think back to a day in your recent past
did things go the way you expected did
everything and everyone follow the
script you planned
unfortunately business and life can be
quite chaotic unpredictable and even
messy
how can we better prepare ourselves to
manage all of this spontaneity in a
creative collegial way
i'm matt abrahams and i teach strategic
communication at stanford graduate
school of business
today i am really looking forward to
speaking with christian wheeler who is
the gsb stratacom professor of
management and professor of marketing
christian teaches a variety of courses
including those on behavioral research
marketing management and spontaneous
management
welcome christian
hi matt great to be here
i've really enjoyed working with you on
a few projects at the gsb you seem to
have unending energy and are amazing to
watch teach i'm so excited about our
conversation should we get started
yeah let's do it all right
as i mentioned in the beginning things
don't always go as planned you teach a
course in spontaneous management can you
share with us two or three of the key
learnings you impart to your students
we all spend time making plans whether
those are business plans such as a
quarterly earnings
forecast or personal plan such that we
rehearse in our minds the way a
conversation or interaction is going to
go
and things rarely turn out exactly like
we anticipated and and that can be
upsetting to people can throw them off
of their game and so
the class of spontaneous management is
built around this idea of providing
people a sense of calm and flexibility
so that they can adapt to whatever
circumstances come about so
um i know you know you talk a lot with
your students about managing anxiety
a lot of people feel
anxious you know even giving a planned
scripted presentation in front of others
and how much worse is that when you're
dealing with circumstances that you
can't completely control such as a
question and answer session that uh goes
differently than you anticipated or just
being asked to make spontaneous remarks
about something uh so
one thing that we deal with right at the
beginning of the classes is just
learning to be comfortable being
uncomfortable you know all of us have
some natural reaction of arousal when we
get in situations like that and that's
not necessarily a good or a bad thing
what is good or bad is how we respond to
that sense of arousal and so
sometimes when we get in these
situations where we need to make
unplanned comments we can get a little
anxious
and then we get anxious about being
anxious we feel bad about being anxious
and that's that's where the problem
starts there's nothing wrong with with
being uncomfortable the problem is with
your discomfort at being uncomfortable
and so we work on exercises teaching
people to to be in that situation and to
respond in that situation with a sense
of calm they can acknowledge that they
feel a little bit anxious but they're
not going to dwell on it and they're
going to trust their minds to bubble up
the necessary responses that they have
in that moment and it's when we start
layering other things on top of that
feeling of arousal or anxiety that it
becomes problematic you know if you've
ever watched american football you know
they talk about how the the best
quarterbacks have to have a short-term
memory
what that means is if you go out and you
make a mistake you throw an interception
the next time you go out there you can't
be thinking about that interception you
just threw you need to be thinking about
in the moment what you need to be doing
to adapt to that next series of plays
that you have and so
the less you time you can spend dwelling
on your mistakes the more mental energy
you can devote to doing what you need to
do in that moment
so i really i really like that advice
and
a lot of this is just acknowledging that
that getting nervous in those types of
situations is normal and natural rather
than something that is bizarre and
strange most people get that way and
then and then that can help
short-circuit some of that anxiety
you're talking about do you do you work
with your students on specific things
they can do to develop that short-term
memory and to help reduce some of that
feeling bad about feeling nervous
yeah absolutely so i guess that was
going to bring me to the second thing we
work on uh having a sense of not fearing
failure so failure is another thing this
is similar you need a similar set of
responses failure is not something that
we seek and no one wants to fail but the
fear of failure can create these uh
layer all of these other maladaptive
responses on top of that and so what we
do is we put people into situations a
lot some exercises we do early on are
what improvisers call brain frys
they're situations where your brain
simply can't compute all of the
necessary information
and you learn to be in those situations
with a sense of comfort
at least relative comfort and you learn
to treat failure as something that's
okay
you know here in silicon valley we have
this mantra many companies do of failing
fast failing quickly and all of that and
that's fine as an intellectual
orientation
uh but many of us when we're confronted
with personal failure even with things
that are not high stakes uh it feels bad
to us
and we work hard to try to avoid that
failure and and that can often be
counterproductive so we try to encourage
people to
accept failure as being something that's
okay and to to enter situations like
that with a with a sense of play and a
sense of joy
i once heard a a wonderful bit of advice
that
just because you failed doesn't mean
you're a failure failing can actually be
a wonderful learning opportunity but it
sounds like what you're trying to
inculcate in your students is this idea
that that failing isn't bad and and it's
something that you can actually
desensitize yourself to
failing is something that that's on the
pathway to success you know people
forget what it was like to be a young
child children are bad at everything
right they don't they don't know how to
walk they don't know how to use a spoon
they don't know how to tie their shoes
they can't do anything and children fail
and fail and fail and fail and fail
until they stop failing and so
a young person is used to failing all
the time it's no big deal and and
through failure they learn how to gain
the skills that they need to to
participate in life and as adults we we
get to some point where
we can structure our own environments in
such a way that we don't put ourselves
in failure situations and and that's
where we stop growing we need to
recognize that failure is a great thing
because failure
suggests that we are operating at the
outside of our abilities and that we
have some skills that we can acquire to
better adapt to our circumstances you
know you remind me of a company i worked
for many years ago we had failure
fridays and the ceo essentially rewarded
people for stepping forward and
acknowledging some work failure they had
with the idea being one what you're
saying there is to push ourselves to try
new things and of course when you try
new things failure happens but also to
be an educational experience so it was
okay to fail but let's not make the same
mistake again so those failure fridays
were actually quite fun and people would
compete to have the biggest failure and
it turned into quite an event but it was
really something that helped desensitize
people to failure and encourage learning
yeah i love that idea i love that idea
and then everyone else can learn from
your failures as well right they learn
what didn't work and and it's and it
destigmatizes your own failure that's
great absolutely so in your course you
talk about creative collaboration
can you provide us with some practical
tips on how we can be more creative in
our collaboration
sure so you know one of the things we
work on in my courses is understanding
your tendencies so all of us have uh
we're exist along some continuum of
either wanting to seize control or
wanting to avoid control
and so we do some exercises aimed at
helping you understand your basic
tendencies and then within that to
recognize that the things that your
collaboration partners are giving you
are are gifts
so what a lot of people
don't fully appreciate about the the
creative process is
the value of
inputs that come outside of your own
brain whether they're from your
environment or whether they're from
someone else that you're collaborating
with
but arthur kessler talks about this as
having intersecting reality planes right
we have two different ways of viewing
the world each of us has our own
perspective our own set of experiences
our own set of associations
and that when those things intersect
that's when you can have interesting
creative solutions and so when we're
working alone we can do things to foster
that process but the collaborative
process naturally creates that type of
thing and so one thing we work on
is viewing
inputs as gifts or as an improviser
would say as an offer as something to be
built upon
and so if you've read anything or heard
anything about improvisational theater
you know that the first rule is yes and
and so what we do is we we affirm what
the person gave us and then we build
directly on that idea and what people
who do these exercises with me find is
that they come up with crazy innovative
solutions that they never would have
been able to dream up on their own just
by having that additional person provide
an input into them
so do you teach your students or do you
have some recommendations for some
ground rules or some directives that can
help people
feel okay being creative and saying yes
and there's a lot of pressure to to get
things right and and i feel like that
stifles this yes and approach
yeah absolutely so i think what's
important in the sessions i teach on
creativity it's important to just to
know which stage of the creative solving
process that you're in
um we often have a tendency to judge our
ideas at the same time we're creating
them and that's something that humans
are not good at doing there's a time to
judge but that's not the time when
you're creating ideas you can judge
ideas later
so you essentially encourage people to
one recognize are we in the
brainstorming and ideation phase or are
we in a different phase and in that
ideation phase
anything goes let's not judge let's
really focus on how we can see what
others are saying or offers
yes and to build upon those things
because we don't know the value of an
idea until we follow it to its logical
conclusion and even if we end up
someplace that isn't super valuable for
us we may find that there are aspects of
that idea that are still valuable that
we could incorporate in a different way
certainly and and i can only imagine
that in interacting with others in that
way collaborating in that way it builds
trust and camaraderie so that perhaps
that idea wasn't good but it might lead
to the creation of other good ideas yeah
i think that's exactly right you know
people are thinking a lot more about
issues of diversity equity and inclusion
and i think that's really important to
think about you know in any given
context you may be an individual who
feels that you belong or feels that your
contributions are valued or feel like
you have something useful to say
and the way people respond to your
initial ideas are are probably going to
affect the way that you interact in that
environment what i mean by that is you
know you mentioned that there's some
evaluation apprehension associated with
a group decision making context right i
don't want to say something stupid or be
judged for that and i have some
threshold for how good i think an idea
is before i'm going to let it come out
of my mouth and then i'm going to look
to people's responses to that and if
that initial response is negative the
next time around that threshold may be a
little bit higher
and so it's very
easy to unintentionally stifle the
voices of people who may have varying
levels of comfort with contributing
because they feel that they they belong
in that group or don't one thing that
this orientation does is it makes sure
that you're hearing all voices even
those who may be a little more reluctant
to speak up initially oh and that is so
critical for not only good
decision-making and feeling part of a
group but just for furthering this cause
of diversity and inclusion beyond
focusing on spontaneity and management
you did some research on what you
referred to as positive implying
pronouns can you give us the scoop on
how our language use specifically
pronouns might help us in our
communication
sure so the pronouns that we use um
indicate something about the
relationships that we have with others
or the norms of the situation
so that research was about the language
that businesses use to communicate to
customers so if i'm in a joint business
venture with somebody loosely speaking
meaning that
i'm a banker trying to communicate to a
potential client or i'm an insurance
company trying to communicate to a
potential client how do i talk about
that relationship
one way we could phrase that is i could
say you and i will work together to meet
your financial needs
or i could say we will work together to
meet those financial needs
and what research shows is that when
people use pronouns like we that is
indicating implicitly but in a way that
people pick up on it's indicating
closeness and a shared identity so if
you look at committed relationship
partners they use the words we more
often than not we our and us
this pronoun that implies this
togetherness versus separateness
pronouns such as i me or you
and if you look at the spontaneous
language of couples couples who use
these inclusive pronouns like we
have higher relationship satisfaction
than ones who use i and so it can be an
indicator of the type of relationship
that you have
and it can also increase relationship
satisfaction when you when you tend to
use those pronouns but how successful
that will be will depend on the existing
norms of the situation so in a business
context what our research showed is that
there are certain industries for which
people have expectations of a closer
relationship
and other industries where they feel
they have an expectation of a more
distant relationship and that people
responded more positively when the
pronouns used reflected those existing
norms that people had in their minds
we also know that the use of the pronoun
you just referring to you as you
can increase what psychologists call
self-referencing which means that you
are relating the information to yourself
so if i say something like computer
technology is changing every day or i
could say matt you know the computer
technology is changing every day just
adding that you there
makes you more likely to think about
that information in a self-relevant way
just along the lines of using someone's
name which relates to some other
research that i've done
interesting so using you using someone's
name invites people to pay attention and
then do some self-reflection
in a way that they might not if you
don't use that language that's right
yeah so we recently published a paper
showing that just putting someone's name
in the subject line of an email even
when they know that you already knew
their name
increases their likelihood of opening
the email and increases the likelihood
of generating sales lead or having them
click through to another page and
interestingly it decreases unsubscribes
and the the way it has this effect is
through increasing elaboration of the
information in the message so if you
provide compelling reason to adopt the
product or to browse on the web page
then they're more likely to do that when
you use their name in the subject line
even again when they know that you know
their name such as with stanford alums
or an existing customer of a company
fascinating you know you you talked
about and we talked about this notion of
rapport and bonding and feeling part of
something it goes without saying that
teams that know each other well tend to
work better together unfortunately we
don't always have time to bond with our
colleagues or perhaps with our new
ubiquitous remote work we don't have the
benefit of in-person for lack of a
better term schmoozing i've seen you
help teams bond rapidly
what advice and guidance can you provide
to help us get to know our co-workers
better and more quickly
you raise a really
good issue there this remote working
thing is is dramatically changing the
way that organizations function i think
so
one fear that people had when if people
are coming into the office and i'm not
there to look over their shoulder maybe
i'm worried they're not gonna get any
work done that turns out from what i've
seen not to be true people are certainly
capable of supervising themselves and
getting work done but what we
do miss is this contact that we have
with people you know stopping by their
office or running to them and running
into them at the water cooler these
little interactions with one another
have a huge effect on the level of
bonding that we feel with one another so
we know that proximity for example is
one of the the biggest predictors of
attraction that just means how close we
are to individuals you know you're more
likely to be friends with someone who
has an office or cubicle next door to
you than someone who has an office or
cubicle on a second floor
and also there's this principle
developed by bob zions who was a
stanford psychology professor before he
passed away called mere exposure simply
coming into contact with something
repeatedly makes us like it more and so
these
little interactions that we though we
may not feel that they're a critical
component of our organizational
functioning have a huge effect on how
close we feel to one another and when we
have those frequent and positive
interactions they form the foundation
for trust and the foundation of trust
helps us identify more with our
organization and the organizational
mission
and what we've seen here with meetings
for example is that we often think of
the purpose of meetings is just to be
the things that are on the agenda sheet
but what we see is that meetings have a
lot of other functions they serve these
socialization functions even if it's not
an explicit part of the meeting you know
we show up to the table a few minutes
early or lingerie or a few minutes
afterwards and we have this incidental
contact with others that is taken away
when we're working in this remote
environment one thing that organizations
need to think about is ways to
artificially induce that into this more
formal zoom style interaction that we've
adopted
so in my in my exercises what you know
what we do is we have people engage in
exercises where they're interacting with
one another they're experiencing this
positive affect and they're engaging in
some degree of self-disclosure which is
something that creates the foundations
of trust can you give an example of one
or two examples of uh an activity that
you do i've seen you do multiple ones
i'm curious if one or two
bubble to the top that you'd like to
share
oh yeah they can be very very simple
things such as
minor acts of self-disclosure i have
people um for example psychologists have
have developed these series of questions
to create rapport in the lab
artificially so oftentimes people may
want to study closer versus more distant
relationships but when you just bring
friends versus strangers into the lab
there are all kinds of confounds but
what they've developed is is a series of
questions with escalating levels of
self-disclosure that can create these
feelings of a close relationship even
with someone that you've met just mere
minutes ago and so one thing we do is we
have bring people through those
questions and they escalate in a way
such that people generally feel
comfortable revealing something about
themselves so it's not too fast but it's
faster than you probably would normally
in an ordinary conversation with someone
so give me an example of one of those
questions
well you start out with things such as
you know matt how long have you been to
stanford why did you come here this type
of thing
moving you know through a series of
questions in a series of stages to get
to more uh you know the last level we're
talking about things like an
embarrassing experience that you learn
from or or something you really want to
accomplish in the next 20 years that's
close to your heart so it's it's a
gradual escalation where where each
person reveals a little bit so they feel
more connected as they go
that's right that's right and what we've
seen through research is that we like
people who self-disclose to us and we
like people more when we self-disclose
to them this notion of self-disclosure
in a virtual world i've done this with
some of the the students i teach and and
some of the the folks i coach where
we'll just say take something in the
room you're sitting in and just show it
to us uh virtually it's like show and
tell when we were kids but it's a way of
disclosure because people will explain
why it's important it also has this
wonderful side effect of making people
turn on their videos and people are
loathed to do that sometimes so it feeds
into what you're discussing
yeah that's an interesting thing that we
see with zoo meetings now is that we we
get glimpses into people's lives that we
wouldn't ordinarily have right we see
their their living rooms and their
children and their pets and so people
are often engaging in in unintentional
forms of self-disclosure that still give
us the feeling of knowing that person
better absolutely i think you can
connect to people much more when you see
more of them for sure i'd like to move
on and i know that you use improv games
to help your students better understand
the concepts you teach and i'm wondering
if you'd be willing to play a quick
improv game that i just made up all
right let's do it okay i'm going to name
a business activity and i'd like for you
to respond with the first thing that
comes to your mind sure all right here
we go
email
hell
[Laughter]
tell me why what are your thoughts on
email and any advice on how to make it
better
you know email is a bad form of
communication i mean some of it is is
our own fault for example i'm not as
good as i could be at managing my
inboxes and keeping personal things
separate from from work things but even
within a work in box you know there are
some things that are very important
things that are unimportant and so you
know one thing we can do as senders for
example is to clearly indicate in the
subject line whether this is something
that requires action on my part whether
this is something that's just for my
information whether this is a newsletter
or or that type of thing because we end
up in this endless task without clear
prioritization there are various
technological solutions that can help
with that but but nothing's perfect and
then also you know emails tend to be
too long
they're not prioritized efficiently and
so it's easy to you know start drowning
in the swamp
of email we um yeah on this podcast
we've talked in the past about how
structure can really help you when
you're you're trying to be efficient and
concise and and just thinking about how
to structure an email rather than just
listing bullet points can really help so
so i agree being more concise and direct
is is helpful let me give you the last
activity i'd like your thoughts on
performance reviews
uh approach oh tell me more what you
mean about that
uh
i i think it's incredibly useful to to
seek feedback and i think most of us
tend not to do that as much as we should
when we think about performance review
when we're on the receiving end of that
that's often a source of evaluation
apprehension or anxiety uh when we're on
the giving end of that that can often be
the source of uncomfortable
conversations but you know the only way
you learn how you're doing is through
through seeking performance feedback and
i think people should do it more
frequently than than they do
and again if they have this orientation
that receiving negative feedback is
something on the pathway to growth then
that can take some of the potential
sting out of hearing news that you don't
necessarily want to hear oh i like that
that approach really does change and it
feeds right back into what you talked
about seeing things as offers and gifts
i mean in some ways performance reviews
are gifts they're tools to help you
better yourself uh just taking that
mindset versus oh i'm being judged
evaluated i have to defend myself that
that could really change how these
things go
yeah absolutely and talking to you know
all of the communications uh lecturers
at stanford that set is fantastic at
doing they continually seek student
feedback in an open-ended way and they
continually revise their class so that
they can better meet the needs of the
students i'm blushing christian thank
you
before we end i'd like to ask the same
three questions of everybody that i
speak with and i'm hoping you'll join me
in this sure
if you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title what would it be
five words i would say uh make a
connection with others okay tell me more
well that sounds a little a little trite
on the surface of it but there are lots
of things that we do that can that can
increase or decrease uh our likelihood
of doing that when i first came to
stanford we had communication coaches
that that helped us improve our teaching
and i got some
fabulous advice that i i never forgot
one is i used to wander around a lot
when i was speaking um i was you know i
don't know if it was nervous energy or i
thought it was kicky
it tends to be very distracting for
people they're moving their heads around
like they're watching a tennis match
the communications instructor said to me
i want you to hold on to this podium and
don't let go
i want you to just stand right here and
do not move and when you do that when
you can deliberately use stillness in
your body it gives you incredible power
as a communicator when you can move with
intention and also not move with
intention so you can create this gravity
and stillness when you want to and then
you can create a break
another thing that that person said is
to make extended eye contact with people
that's something i didn't bring up in
the bonding thing that we were talking
about earlier right but what this coach
said she says look i want you to just
pick one person in the audience and look
at them for a few seconds and then i
want you to look at another person pick
them and make eye contact with them for
a few seconds
so she said don't don't do the general
sweep
or look into the far distance as though
you're watching a sunset in the horizon
she says i want you to pick specific
individuals and and make extended eye
contact contact with them and what you
find is that boy
that person is being looked at they're
paying attention to what you're saying
and interestingly the other people in
the room don't feel neglected by that as
an audience member that's a totally fine
thing to watch but as the person being
looked at it makes that very strong
connection yeah and we're actually
finding that that looking at the camera
when doing virtual communication has a
similar effect so so looking at the
camera makes the people on the other end
feel like you're talking directly to
them
absolutely and it's so hard to do
because you're trained to make eye
contact with people which virtually
assures that you're not looking directly
into the camera right so let me ask you
question number two uh who is a
communicator that you admire and why
ah
well that's
i don't normally think about
communicators that i admire or not i
guess so i'm gonna say i'll give you a
weird answer i'm gonna say elizabeth
strout
okay i want more information
she's a novelist i you know we often
don't think of when we think of
communicators we haven't think of
orators or
business leaders but i think novelists
are clearly communicators and what i
like about her she's a fabulous writer
but
good novelists
reveal that they have very keen powers
of empathy and observation so she writes
about a person olive kitterage who is a
dislikable person but she's the
protagonist of many of her books
and through placing you in the mind of
olive you gain a level of empathy with
her and so for elizabeth to be able to
do that she needs to both understand
what a person like that is like and then
to be able to convey that to you in a
way that you empathize with it and so i
think to be a good communicator you need
to have keen powers of observation you
need to be able to read the people in
the audience and and understand you know
their reactions and how they're
responding to you and you also need to
have that empathy to take their point of
view to understand what they want to get
out of that interaction and when
novelist can do that in a way
particularly by depicting dislikable
people as someone that you can still
identify with i think is just incredible
i'm smiling because i'm thinking a good
novelist has to be able to read his or
her audience so that the audience in
turn will read their stuff so a lot of
reading that has to happen there
what are the first three ingredients
that go into a successful communication
recipe
okay
well the first one i'll double up on a
bit i guess i'll say attentiveness you
need to be attentive to the situation
another one i would say would be
vulnerability and the third one i would
say is openness um i mean this in a way
that it's an orientation toward the
world of curiosity
and lack of judgment that if i'm really
going to be engaging in a successful
interaction with you i i need to listen
to the things that you're saying with a
sense of curiosity
and a lack of judgment so that that i
can respond in a in a truly open way
well christian all of us have been
listening to you with a an intense uh
curiosity and we have learned so much i
thank you for sharing with us your
insights into communication to my mind
what i heard you say is it it all boils
down to approach having a an open
approach seeking offers being open to
failure really
being attentive and responsive to the
needs of those you're communicating with
can make a huge difference thank you for
your time and thank you for your
insights
thanks matt
[Music]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast
produced by stanford university's
graduate school of business for more
information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu
or subscribe to our show wherever you
get your podcasts
finally find us on social media at
stanford.gsb